joining us here future hall-of-famer was
there part of NFL network's coverage my
colleague Joe Thomas how are you Joe
okay so let's walk through it here I'm
you know I've done that Thursday night
thing for a very very long time and I
know you're on the field usually a few
minutes before getting ready to go on
the air were you on that side of the
field where this happened well that was
actually the big challenge for us from
the NFL Network trying to get ready for
the postgame show as you know we're kind
of hovered around the desk area yes
we're talking with the producers talking
about what cut-ups we want to see what
stats were going to talk about and this
happened at the complete other end of
the field and all I could hear was the
joke bok choy and call on my ear and
immediately I whipped my head up to try
to catch the video board to see if we
could see because it was so far away you
couldn't even see what was going on and
as you know in those NFL stadiums a lot
of times when really bad the egregious
stuff is happening they just cut that
video feed out so we didn't even get to
see it or look at it until well after it
was over and we huddled around the
little TVs they have right by our set
and we were able to finally get a replay
of it right before we went live on air
and that's kind of when you saw it for
the first time and we're really
horrified by the way things unfolded so
I mean how does something like this
happen Joe or or is it or is it
inexplicable obviously you've been in
entrenches I just give you the floor on
that subject yeah I think it's
inexplicable I mean you talk about miles
Garrett everybody that knows him will
say he's one of the most measured even
keel guys you know he's he plays hard
he's a defensive player to your
candidate but to talk about being out of
character is really an understatement
for something of this magnitude and
really you could say the game was chippy
but it wasn't like there was all sorts
of unnecessary roughness personal fouls
between the different line plays during
that game and so I think it really was
something that was almost completely out
of left field and you heard marques
County it was like he blacked out miles
Garrett blacked out and those things
happen so quickly that people around him
weren't able to bring them back off the
ledge in time for things that just
completely erupted on
Ravel well I'm assuming you shouldn't
just assume you agree that the
suspension for miles Garrett was
appropriate absolutely we came on right
after the game and we were speculating
you know almost in real time that he
would likely be done for the rest of the
season six games left for the Browns and
that seems like it's probably the
minimum at this point from the NFL and
then what do you think about Pouncy
because he was reacting it was in a wild
reaction and one that that obviously is
a bad look but he you know he's never
seen that I've never seen that I mean do
you think three games is too much for
that Joe I thought actually the NFL was
pretty spot-on coming down with
suspensions today what we saw from
Marquis Pouncy we completely understand
defending your quarterback defending
your teammates coming to their aid
myself as a former offensive lineman I
understand the importance of defending
your guys especially that quarterback
position but I think it goes beyond
defending your quarterback when the
person you're attacking is laying on the
ground has given up and your other
offensive lineman David de Castro is
laying on them and you're stomping and
kicking them and trying to punch them
that becomes punitive and a retribution
it's not any longer defending your
quarterback you're trying to get back
for your quarterback and I believe
that's why the NFL thought that it's
just not a good look because we consider
crossing the line as an NFL family when
you start kicking you're punching
you're stomping you're swinging helmets
those are all things that are over the
line and beyond reproach we understand
some wrestling matches we understand
things can get heated pushing and
shoving those are part of the games
those are fights that we see all the
time but I think as soon as you elevate
it to the kicking and the stomping and
the swinging of helmets that's when
you're crossing line and I don't mean to
try to compare what Pouncy did with what
miles that's completely not what I'm
saying
what miles did was way beyond anything
that Pouncy did but I believe that
bouncies suspension was correct because
he also crossed the line and went above
and beyond just merely defending his
quarterback well Joe you you're
perfect guest to have on right now for
many reasons one you were there - you're
a future hall-of-fame lineman and three
you have been in as I mentioned trenches
where things can can can get overheated
so on this front we're already seeing
first blush my my my goat friend Charles
Woodson tweeted out are we allowed to
look at this from both sides a manual
h.o has been tweeting his will somebody
who's been in the line of fire if you
will football wise about Mason Rudolph
essentially tugging on on the head of
Miles Garrett to begin with do you think
rudolph bears any responsibility
whatsoever in all of this
jo well i think it's fair to kind of
look back on things and say alright you
know how did we get to this point but
from my perspective i look at it like i
do when i talk to my kids you know my
daughter hits my son in the face and i
say that's not acceptable i don't care
what he said you i don't care what he
did to you to precipitate this you
crossed the line and that's never
acceptable so while a lot of people want
to say mason rudolph started it by
trying to rip Garrett's helmet off and
going back at him a second time it's not
acceptable to ever react the way that
miles did and so i doesn't matter to me
at all what Mason would all swoll and
starting it or instigating it was
whatsoever and I'll leave that up to the
Pittsburgh Steelers to decide how to
handle it and who bears the book the
brunt of the blame of why we got to such
a terrible moment in the game last night
what do you think is gonna happen in two
weeks when they see each other again I
mean ten days literally well you know
it's interesting because this was such
an explosive fight such an explosive end
to the game it's almost like things
could possibly simmer out and sizzle out
by that time and and I there's a great
opportunity we're cooler heads prevail
and it's a very boring mundane standard
game because a lot of the players that
were involved in this won't even be
playing in that game because it is such
a recent game and you talk about the
suspensions with Marquis penalties for
three games and miles Garrett for the
rest of the season so I could definitely
this being a non-event game but on the
flip side of the coin there could be a
lot of heat from this game still and
there was one thing we haven't even
talked about and that was the Odell
Beckham Jarvis Landry sort of mocking
Mike Tomlin with the yawning after the
touchdown and then Oh BJ and Mike Talman
kind of gone back and forth during the
game I wasn't completely overlooked but
definitely would have been a storyline
the rest of this game and kind of how
that rivalry is taken off a little bit
and then moving into two weeks and so
it'll be interesting to see how the
storylines potentially could ship on the
miles Garrett Mason Rudolph fight - all
right Tomlin versus the Browns receivers
and Pittsburgh Steelers versus the
Cleveland Browns because we did see some
big hits in the secondary specifically
oh yeah in this game early on that could
you know that type of stuff could boil
over in a couple weeks yeah that's right
at 17 days is when they play not really
ten but it's in two weeks time on the
football counter you're talking about
damarious Randall got the gate for
knocking out I believe Deante Johnson
last night and the juju Smith Shuster
also got concussed he got knocked out of
the game Joe Thomas here on the Rich
Eisen show well how do you think Baker
Mayfield's comments about right on the
spots that it was inexcusable and that
you know it's we've been hurting
ourselves too much around here that's
been it's sort of the been the issue how
do you think those comments make even
though I thought they were spot-on and
leader showing a sign of leadership that
that's required what do you think Joe
yeah well let me quick talk about the
hits in the secondary um you know we
talked about damarious Randall getting
food for his penalty those hits in the
secondary while they were violent and
there was some players that got knocked
out and thrown out they were not
intentional there was nobody had hunting
it was one of those things that kind of
happened throughout the course of the
game when you're playing fast they were
the right call certainly but there was
no malicious intent similar to what we
saw at the end of the game and now
specifically to what Baker did at the
end of the game I actually thought that
was one of the bright moments at the end
of the game for the Browns because Baker
Mayfield had an opportunity to kind of
brush it under the rug and say well wait
to see the film we
wait and you know not rush to judgment
on this but he actually showed me a
tremendous amount of leadership and I
think he's got an opportunity to have
this team really rally around him with
the way he handled it with the media
right away standing up taking ownership
saying this is not how we act this is
not who we are as a team and to me that
was a huge step and could be a really a
pivotal moment in Baker Mayfield's
career because of the leadership he
showed in that moment I thought it was
his finest hour to be honest with you
Joe oh you know I agree and also showed
to me that you know you could say sure
he's cocky confident all that but he's
confident in his grasp of the locker
room that he could be confident in and
to say something like that in my mind
absolutely absolutely yeah I think most
quarterbacks probably would sit there
and talk in cliches and really give you
a non-answer but he was very definitive
I thought he showed tremendous amount of
leadership by standing up and attacking
it right away even though Myles is a
good friend and Myles is one of the
leaders on that defense and for all the
people that know Myles they understand
how out of character that play was for
him but to stand up there and say this
is just not acceptable this is not how
we play
he showed that this is his team and I
agree that was to me his finest moment
as a quarterback and it had nothing to
do with how he played so in the few
minutes I have with you left here Joe
you know after the game Freddie kitchen
said this is not what we're about and
the Haslam family just sent out a
statement that said the same thing
all that said do you think any of this
is gonna wind up at the feet of Freddie
kitchens talking about undisciplined
behavior talk about not having control
that other coaches no player would ever
consider doing that because they'd be
afraid of the ramifications that's
normally what does come with the
territory where the first-year head
coach is only won four out of his first
ten despite the two game win streak well
that's going to be part of the learning
process for this young Browns roster and
understanding that what you do in the
actions that you take on the field have
repercussions not only for yourself in
your teammates but your
coaches in your organization in your
city because the message really the
beginning of the season was Freddie
kittens doesn't have control his team
because of the undisciplined play
because of the penalties and they had
gotten better in the last three weeks
with those things and then to have
something like this only adds fuel to
the fire of does Freddie kitchens have
control of this team does he have
control these players where they're
afraid to act a certain way that hurts
the team because they know how hard
Freddie kitchens going to come down on
it and right wrong or indifferent when
there is something like this that
happens that becomes part of the
narrative around the team and I think
when I talked to Myles here this morning
I'm in umbria this morning I got a
chance to talk to him you can see how
upset and remorseful he was not only for
his own actions but how it's affecting
everybody around him not only what he
did to Mason Rudolph and how he sparked
such an ugly moment at the end of the
game but now the questions that his
teammates are gonna have to answer about
the coaching staff and Freddie kitchens
in particular because that is a tough
narrative to overcome and when you have
something as big and momentous as what
we saw at the end of a game that's just
going to only be that fire that people
especially people that might not like
Freddie as a coach want to say about him
how he's lost control of that locker
room well okay so before I let you go so
you you saw Myles Garrick this very
morning is what you're saying yeah well
I'm like I mentioned I'm in Cleveland
here for the Thursday night game and I
also do the Browns radio show the day
after their games and Myles and I have
been friends since he was here as a
rookie and we had some great battles
training camp and after I hurt my elbow
I you know wanted to try to help him out
as much as I could because I could see
what that player and person he could be
and so I wanted to help him kind of
think like an offensive lineman so every
week I'd give him scouting reports and
talk to him about the tackles he was
going to face and you could just see how
bad he felt this morning and talking to
him how he was so remorseful and that as
soon as almost that helmet swing was
over and he was laying on the ground he
realized what he had done and how
embarrassed he was for himself for his
team for
family for everybody around him and I
feel like he's ready to accept the
consequences that the NFL just laid out
with the indefinite suspension well it's
not just that to Joe I mean he's gonna
be public enemy number one for quite
some time and and I you know I laced
into him too and I don't know him all
that well and that's not what I do
that's not why I sit in this chair
that's not how I operate I know you and
I haven't really worked on the same set
or the same show you know you and I have
spoken on the phone not just here but
you know a little bit off off the air
that's not what I'm about I'm not about
you know what I'm gonna make some hay
and get some clicks on my show by laying
into Miles Garrett I'm genuinely pissed
as somebody who's worked at the NFL
Network for 16 years my job is to talk
the NFL and and hopefully be part of the
continuing growth of the sport it puts
everybody in a bad spot and everybody in
danger and and and it's a terrible
terrible thing for him to have done I'm
trying to just piece it all together how
is he going to handle all that do you
think well right now obviously dealing
with the repercussions like I mentioned
for everybody for everybody in NFL
family because in the end we might be
competitors on the field but we're all
brothers in this business together
because you're getting traded you're
signing with new teams your friendships
that cross across team lines and when
you do something like what miles did
yesterday it's a bad look for everybody
and I think he's starting to understand
the gravity of that situation and
unfortunately for him I can stand here
and say that's not who he is that's out
of character people that know him can
defend him and say that's not who he is
but that's who he was last night and
that's who people that don't know him
CMS and you know what your actions
become who you are and so until you
change your actions
that's who you're going to be known as
and we can talk about what a great
person he is and how this is really a
one thing on the radar but it's a huge
thing and you know what you can only use
that excuse about you know I'm just not
a bad kid but I ran with bad kids and I
was
bad circle no it's about you and
personal responsibility and owning up to
your actions and so I think it's now the
onus is on Miles to move forward from
this and become a better person and
prove that that was not him that night
and so last one for you when you said to
him did you say to him like what what
happened now that he's half of a day
removed from it and and the cameras
aren't on him like what happened yeah he
was just totally I think lost in the
moment similar to what you heard from
Marquis bouncy like you black out I've
been involved in you know a few
locker-room type fights training camp
type sites and you you hear guys say
that a lot like their rage and their
anger gets so high they're not even
there you look at them in the eyes and
there's nothing behind it they're
they're almost on autopilot and you know
I believe that's that's exactly what
happened was miles but you can tell just
from talking with him this morning that
he cannot wait to move on beyond this
and prove that that was just an
abomination and totally not who he was
and I believe he's going to do
everything he can to try to make this
right from this point forward to jail
great work last night appreciate the
call today truly thank you all right
thanks right back at you that's Joe
Thomas at Joe Thomas 73 on Twitter for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel - 39 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app